[MUSIC PLAYING]
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
Hi, everyone.
Welcome back to Google
Developers Live.
My name is Claudio.
I'm an engineer on the
Google Drive SDK
Developer Relations team.
And this Eric, our
tech lead for the
documentation on the same team.
Welcome, Eric.
This is the first time
for you live.
ERIC GILMORE: Thank
you, Claudio.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And today,
we want to talk about our
documentation.
We got a lot of feedback
on our documentation.
And Eric spent a lot of time
working through that feedback,
and he's going to share some
of the results with you.
ERIC GILMORE: I hate to start
by correcting you, Claudio.
But a lot of feedback is
a slight exaggeration.
And we always want
more feedback.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
ERIC GILMORE: That's why the
very first thing we're going
to show you when we switch to
this monitor is a new feature
in our SDK documentation, which
is this link here at the
upper right, which you
can use to send
feedback directly to me.
I'll share it with the
team, of course.
And we'll act on your feedback
as quickly as we can and as
thoroughly as we can.
But this right here, I'd like
to show you, is the link.
You can type some things,
hopefully something a little
bit more intelligible
than that.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah,
and remember,
he is the tech writer.
So that was absolutely
meaningful.
ERIC GILMORE: And I think
this is a great feature.
You can actually highlight
screenshots, verbiage,
whatever you'd like
to talk about,
and submit that feedback.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
What about the other button
there, the blackout?
ERIC GILMORE: Ah.
If you want to remove some
information that you would
like to hide from the world,
personal information about
yourself, pictures of your
children, your name, whatever,
you can black it
out like that.
And that is what we'll
see when you send the
feedback, like so.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
ERIC GILMORE: We encourage
you to use this link.
Please use it.
We want more feedback.
That's really what I'm saying.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
That's great.
So you said there was a
link on that top right
corner of the page.
Is that available everywhere?
ERIC GILMORE: That should be
available on every page,
starting from our landing page
to the deepest details in our
documentation, including some of
the pages that we're going
to talk about today,
which is here.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
And that is not the only way
for people to give us
feedback, right?
If they have questions, they
also have other channels,
including Stack Overflow, which
is our main channel for
developer questions.
ERIC GILMORE: Sure.
And if you'd like to ask
questions about the
documentation or give feedback
about the documentation there
or in this form, either
way is terrific.
Just make sure that you feel
free to give us your feedback.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Perfect.
And so I said we got
a lot of feedback.
Well, let's say we got
some feedback.
And what kind of feedback
have we got?
ERIC GILMORE: Well, most of or
feedback has centered around
the Getting Started experience
for our Drive SDK.
And acting on it, we've made a
few changes to this page that
we're demonstrating right now.
The main common thread in the
feedback we received on this
page is it was a little bit
confusing what your options
are for integrating
with Drive.
At the moment, we have basically
two levels of
integration.
One level of integration is
basic drive API access, which
enables you to make calls
to the API and receive--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So, for
instance, whenever you want to
write a script or install an
application that reads your
file, writes files to drive,
even a web application is, of
course, fine that wants
to access your
files on Google Drive.
But you don't want your
application to show up
on the Drive UI.
And if instead you want to, you
can also get that, right?
ERIC GILMORE: Yes.
Without giving too much away,
we may have more options in
that general area soon.
But currently, there's that
level, which to get that level
of integration, all you need to
do is enable the drive API
in your API project.
More involved, more complete, we
think more featureful level
of integration is integrating
with the drive UI
and Chrome Web Store.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Why would
a developer do that?
ERIC GILMORE: Well, a developer
might very well like
to have the open width and
create new behavior that we
provide in the Drive UI, which
is essentially what you'd find
in Windows or Mac file systems
where you open a document with
a particular application.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Do we
want to show that?
ERIC GILMORE: I think
we might.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
ERIC GILMORE: Let's
start with Create.
Here are a number of wonderful
Google formats you could use
to create documents, but to
create documents with
applications integrated with
Google Drive, you come to this
More option.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And you
install an application first.
ERIC GILMORE: Ah, there
aren't any Google--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Really?
Any third-party applications?
So maybe we want to install one
from the Chrome website?
ERIC GILMORE: Let's do that.
Great idea, Claudio.
Fortunately, here is the entire
collection of Drive
apps that we can select from.
What do you think, Claudio?
This is your account.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, that's
my personal account.
So feel free to destroy it.
ERIC GILMORE: How about Loupe?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Loupe
seems great, yeah.
ERIC GILMORE: OK,
sign in to add.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, because
we need to sign in.
We opened this page
before loading.
Just reload the page,
and I'm signed it.
So now it knows that I'm me.
And we can actually install
an application.
ERIC GILMORE: At Chrome.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So that's
all you need to install an
application.
Just goes to the Chrome
Web Store, just click
once, and that's it.
ERIC GILMORE: The applications
that you've installed will
show up in your New tab page.
So every time I open one of
those, I'll have the option of
going straight to Loupe.
Or where we started with
this discussion--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
And as soon as we go back here--
so we refresh the page.
And we get a message
saying that an
application was installed.
And in this case, it's Loupe.
And so now, we can create
a new Loupe collage.
Of course, I have
to authorize it.
Feel free to authorize the
application on my behalf since
you're using my account.
ERIC GILMORE: Let's see.
It's not asking for anything
too particular.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: No, we
know this application.
It's very good.
ERIC GILMORE: We've
allowed access.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO:
And then, you can
create a photo collage.
And that's what Loupe can do.
ERIC GILMORE: We don't
need to go that far.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: No, we can
go back to the Drive UI.
What about the Open-With?
ERIC GILMORE: Now, do you have
an image file in here?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: I might.
But even the first file, which
is a PDF, can be something
that I can open with
something else.
ERIC GILMORE: Can we open
that with Loupe?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, it's
probably not confidential.
Not with Loupe.
We have Google Drive here.
ERIC GILMORE: This
is interesting.
I think you can see
pretty clearly how
Open-With is going to work.
We go to this contextual menu.
We select from installed
applications.
For this particular type of
file, our only option appears
to be the Google Drive Viewer.
But here's something that I'm
very happy to show you, is
when we open this file in the
Google Drive Viewer--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And I'm glad
that you opened a file
that is not confidential.
It's not my private document.
I'm glad you did that.
ERIC GILMORE: Excellent.
Down here, we can actually get
a filtered list of Drive apps
that are capable of opening
that type of file.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Can
you go back to that?
I didn't see it.
ERIC GILMORE: Sure.
Can we go back to it this way?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Oh,
it's another topic.
ERIC GILMORE: We have
to do this again.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, so here
you said in the bottom
left corner, we have a new icon
that's added that can
discover apps that can open
this kind of file.
So we, under this new feature
which checks what file you're
looking at, and says, well, I
can open this file with a
Google Drive Viewer, and
you're seeing it.
But if you want, there are
other applications in the
Chrome Web Store that can also
open the file that maybe have
additional functionalities.
And you clicked on it.
And then in the next stop then,
you see that there are
two applications in the Chrome
Web Store that can open that
specific kind of file.
And so if you want, you can
just install one and go
directly from there.
ERIC GILMORE: Now, this is one
of the reasons that you might
want to integrate with Chrome
Web Store and have the full UI
integration.
That's essentially an upsell on
your application that lets
people know that you can open
these documents with your app.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Let's make it
clear because this changed
since Version 1 of
the Drive SDK.
In Version 1, you had to
integrate your application
with the Chrome Web Store
for it to work.
Now, with Version 2 of the API,
which we launched the
Google I/O a month ago, the
installation requirement is
not a requirement anymore.
So you can write your
application that uses the
Drive API, and it works.
But if you want some marketing
material, if you want your
application to be promoted in
the Chrome Web Store, you can
do an extra step and integrate
it with the Web Store and get
all these features so people can
more easily discover your
application.
ERIC GILMORE: Exactly.
So in this sense, Chrome Web
Store is a distribution and
marketing tool, and
a powerful one.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Perfect.
Did we get any more
feedback on this
specific part of the page?
ERIC GILMORE: Well, we did get
some feedback on the Drive SDK
console and some confusion that
exists between the IDs
that you need to specify
in order to have the
full Chrome Web Store.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK, maybe we
can take a look at the APIs
console and see how
that works.
ERIC GILMORE: All right.
Let's have a look.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So this
is still my account.
And this is a project I have
that is fortunately related.
And so in this APIs console,
we basically define our
project and generate the
credentials that we're going
to use to authorize a request.
So in the API Access tab, we
see that we generated some
credentials, and my application
is a web
application.
So what I'm using is a client ID
for web application, which
is that string there.
And then you also need a client
secret, which of course
now is public thanks to Eric.
So I'm going to revoke
it any time soon--
ERIC GILMORE: You'd better
revoke that quickly.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: --so that
no one else can use.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: We mentioned
the client ID many
times in our documentation.
So whenever we talk about client
ID in the Docs, the
client ID is that string there,
which is usually some
numerical string dot apps dot
Google user content account.
Don't rely on that format.
It is a string.
That's all you need to know.
ERIC GILMORE: And when we say
client ID, we mean this entire
string, including the text.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yes, so the
client ID is the entire
string, which looks like
a URL, but it's not.
It's just a string.
It's part of your credentials.
There's another ID we often
mention in our docs.
And that is the app ID.
The app ID can be found
in the Drive SDK
top of the APIs console.
So in the API access, you
generate credentials for any
kind of applications.
But when you want to work, when
you want to build a Drive
SDK application, you also get
this extra tab, which allows
you to specify more features
of the same application,
including your icons, including
what file types your
application can open,
and so on.
And the first thing you see on
this page is the application
ID, or app ID, which
is just a number.
And it's right there
below the title.
ERIC GILMORE: I think the
source of some of the
confusion may have been that
the client ID generally
includes this number at the
beginning of the string, which
is the client ID.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: But you
shouldn't rely on that.
So don't take the client ID,
strip some parts, and generate
the app ID on your own,
and things like that.
Any time you need to refer
to the app ID,
go to the APIs console.
And anytime you need to refer
to the client ID, go to the
other tab in the APIs console.
ERIC GILMORE: Exactly.
And just to remind you, that
other tab is the API Access
tab where you'll find
the client ID.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
And before we close the section,
I just want to remind
you that in order for you to
have the Drive SDK tab in your
project, you have to go to the
Services tab there and enable
the Drive API and the
Drive SDK services.
So we did that in advance.
You will not see the Drive SDK
section until you enable that
here from Services.
So let's say you want
to create an
application, just to summarize.
First, you go to Services,
enable Drive
API and Drive SDK.
Then you go to API Access
and generate your
client ID in secret.
And then you specify the
additional parameters in the
Drive SDK section.
ERIC GILMORE: Right.
What Claudio has just
described is
detailed in this page.
And if you have any difficulty
with it, please hit the
feedback button and
let us know.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK.
Yeah, we have a feedback
button now.
And also, we cover the
same steps in the
tutorials we have.
Because in our recommendation,
we have guides, we have the
reference, but we also
have tutorials.
ERIC GILMORE: Should we
look at those briefly?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah.
ERIC GILMORE: This is one of the
most popular areas of our
documentation.
We're basically an end-to-end
Drive app example for any one
of these languages--
Java, Python, PHP,
Dotnet, and Ruby.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And we can
say we have one for Go in the
works, which is almost ready.
We just need to make it nicer.
And it's going to be
published soon.
And all these tutorials have
a set-up section where we
explain basically
the same thing.
ERIC GILMORE: Yes.
Claudio, you mentioned
revoking access.
Do you want to actually
take care of that now?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: We can
do that any time.
So you have two things
you can do here.
I actually mentioned one.
But we should make it
clear there are two
things you can do here.
The developer can go back
to the APIs console and
regenerate the client secret.
So right now, anyone who was
watching this video can see my
client ID and client secret.
They can copy those
credentials.
ERIC GILMORE: Make sure
you tell them how.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah,
I'm explaining
how to hack my account.
That is going to be fun.
So you can take those
credentials, and you can use
them in your application to
behave like my application.
And so the developer, in this
case, has to go to the APIs
console, go back to the API
Access tab, and click on
regenerate client secret so that
the old one is not valid
anymore, and all the
APIs requesting to
use that will fail.
And I will be the only one
knowing it, so I will
not show it to you.
And I will be only one
that can use that.
ERIC GILMORE: Could that also
be useful for testing to
regenerate client IDs?
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: That can
also be useful for testing
because your application should
be able to handle all
failure use cases.
So there can be errors anywhere
in the interaction
between your application
and the Drive API.
So in your code, you should take
into account that your
application might not be
authorized anymore.
The user might have uninstalled
the app and so on.
And one thing you can do to land
into one of the scenarios
is you go back your APIs
console, change, regenerate
your client secret, and see
what happens, and behave
accordingly.
And that is on the
developer side.
There is also a part
for the user.
So users install the
application.
You've seen me installing
Loupe.
And when I did, the first time
I started the application, I
granted it access to some
specific files and documents
that I wanted the application
to open.
But at any time, I can, of
course, uninstall the app.
But I also can simply revoke
access to the application and
force the application to ask me
for access again the next
time I want to use it.
So the application is still
installed, but it is not
allowed to do requests
on my behalf.
If I want to revoke access, I
have to go to my account page.
And there, I have a list of
applications in size that are
authorized to access my feeds.
This is a long list.
This is all the applications
I've tried and so on.
But one of them is going
to be Loupe.
And next to it there will
be a button that
says, Revoke Access.
And--
ERIC GILMORE: It's not going
to be easy to find.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: No.
Well, you opened
something else.
Anyway--
ERIC GILMORE: I'm glad you
mentioned this, Claudio,
because it is, in fact, part of
the feedback we received.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Oh, I see.
And this is also a very
important use case for
developers to handle.
So you should take into account
that at any time, the
user can revoke access
to your application.
So maybe you have
a valid token.
That token might be invalid
any second.
So if that happens, you as a
developer have to take the
user back to the Grant
Access page and ask
for permission again.
ERIC GILMORE: And handling
that case is important--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Our
tutorials do it.
So if you use our sample
applications in the five
languages that we listed, you
will see how we handled that
specific case.
And the mechanism is basically
what I said.
Take the user back to the Grant
Access page and get a
new valid token.
ERIC GILMORE: By the way, will
it make you mad if I revoke
access to uefa.com?
I think that's not for work.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, this
is not my work account.
ERIC GILMORE: Oh, all right.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Anyway, you
can do it because that was for
the Euro Cup.
So important business
application, and it's probably
not there anymore.
ERIC GILMORE: The UEFA
wasn't really good
news for your country.
So--
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: No,
we lost in the final,
so it's no big deal.
OK, did we get any other piece
of important feedback that we
want to talk about now?
ERIC GILMORE: Well, we enabled
this new feature, which allows
anybody reading the documents to
give us feedback yesterday.
And we've already received one
helpful comment, which was
some of our users want to see
a PDF format or maybe an F2B
format of our documentation.
And we're going to look at
that in the near future.
But frankly, we need
more feedback.
So I'm going to urge you once
more to give it to us through
this link or through
Stack Overflow.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: One of the
feedback I got yesterday
before this link was there was
a face-to-face interaction
with a developer.
And they asked me how to get
all the updates on our
documentation, our
feeds, our API?
So how do we always know what's
new with the APIs?
What channels do we
have for that?
ERIC GILMORE: Well, one simple
static channel is to look at
our release notes, which
we update periodically.
The latest changes are listed
at the top of these sections
and should give you the
information on things that
we've changed most recently.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: So, for
instance, just mentioning the
first item in this list
was a very, very
heavily requested feature.
It was a way for developers to
expose a publicly available
link to a document.
So you have a document
you store
somewhere on Google Drive.
And you want this document to be
downloadable by anyone with
no authentication required.
And this is now available.
And now each element in the
files list, in a list of files
you get with the API has a field
called Web Content Link,
which is the link
to the document.
And it's publicly accessible to
anyone, of course, if the
document is publicly
accessible.
So I mean it's always up to
the user to decide who has
access to a document.
But if the document is now
public, it's also going to be
listed in that field.
ERIC GILMORE: And wherever we
can, we link you into the
relevant areas of the
documentation where you can
see details on these features
that are recently released.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: And,
in fact, that's a JSON
representation of the
file on our API.
What I also required today--
the guy who asked me yesterday
about the channels, I said
that we have another channel
that we use for updates and
people can subscribe to.
And that is our blog.
So we have a blog that
is called Google
Apps Developer Blog.
Maybe we can open it.
So you can just search for
Google Apps Developer Blog.
ERIC GILMORE: I think
that would be it.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Which
is googleappsdevelo
per.blogspot.com.
And we frequently post updates,
tips and tricks, and
any other thing related to
the Drive SDK in the
other Google Apps API.
ERIC GILMORE: I particularly
like this latest post.
It's by Claudio Cherubino.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, must
be a great developer.
ERIC GILMORE: Five things you
didn't know you could do with
the Google Drive API.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Yeah, I
decided to share my secrets.
So yeah, this has been
posted yesterday.
So we post very, very
frequently.
So it's usually every
other day or so.
And we go into detail
for some feeds.
Or we explain some of things
that were not clear and so on.
And of course, you can add
comments to the post if you
think something is not clear
or have questions.
But if you have feedback, I
would say, as Eric said, you
should use the Feedback
Link in the doc.
ERIC GILMORE: Yes, yes.
Let's not forget about
that Feedback Link.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: Don't
forget about it.
Yeah, what we want to say today
is that if you have to
remember one thing from this
video is that there's a
Feedback Link in our doc that
you can now use to give us
more feedback because we
want more feedback.
ERIC GILMORE: Yes, we do.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: OK, and I
think with that, we can wrap
up for today.
Thank you very much
for watching this.
And see you next time.
ERIC GILMORE: Thank you.
CLAUDIO CHERUBINO: See you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]